I don't go to the gym very often
it's a real workout gotta come and shift
the girls in so every single day we're
doing this Trek
in the land of Africa
five-year-old cheetah triplets mathi
muri and fosse wait for keeper Dominique
to serve breakfast
okay I see some kitties
[Music]
this is their auditory Q response
pretty much like their breakfast Bell
a hi hi baby you're my girl a massage in
my opinion is definitely our funniest
cat she's kind of a sweetheart she does
this thing where she'll hiss and spit at
you and then you feed her and she's like
oh I never did that that wasn't me I'm
very nice we don't play favorites but
she's definitely got a special place in
my heart
ready
you can eat for me
yeah
best girl
done
[Music]
I talked to the cats a lot it does help
them to get used to you I wish they
could talk back it would make our job so
much easier if there was something going
on and they were like my stomach's not
feeling gross today all done you
finished
nice job babe now we will see the status
of the other two
nice job Mary
come in for their eats okay you have a
lot here that you dropped so we're gonna
do that no with full bellies it's time
to start the day
hi
good morning
these are my girls I love them so much
they're so cute look at them
[Music]
we got mathi right here taking a nice
break I'm trying to learn their
behaviors so that sometimes if they're
having an off day or an off week we're
able to tell those things
recently mathi has shown some worrying
Behavior
so she's had this gastritis for a while
and sometimes she does have some
flare-ups she has been doing a lot of
regard sometimes it's like a small
amount and sometimes it's a big amount
lately she's regurged pretty much her
whole meal plus some for like a couple
days in a row so that was pretty
concerning one of those things that we
are trying to do with mathi in her
stomach is give her some antacids my
fingers are always crossed and I'm
always hoping for the best that she will
be a little bit better
[Music]
thank you